l
is a much harder person to say
no to that Joe Biden at a 40%
approval exactly. Coming back
to the president in this format
last night. Anderson Cooper.
This sort of this town hall
type thing where voters would
get up there and they ask their
questions and Cooper could
follow up we've
seen this particular in the
campaign trails where this type
of thing
usually happens. It is
definitely different their
follow-ups that's find these
are real questions. But
it's different from a sit-down
get a sustained way with a
journalist that is what you do.
you know in a block on the FOX
News Sunday a high-profile gas
to has a lot
of power. You'll have 13
minutes or something 40 minutes
to really. Challenge that
person.
If you could just from your
perspective explain what you
feel the value is of that type
of setting
that they but I think Biden 10
of them in his entire
presidency, so far why you
think it would be valuable for
the country to have him
challenge in that kind of
setting more often well I mean
it's a little bit like the
president when he and takes
questions on the way out to the
to the helicopter to the on the
South lawn and it was for this
president also Donald Trump.
You know you the basically the
they he's completely in control
his country is in control of
how long he wants to answer how
detail we want central Missouri
wants to take a follow-up from
this reporter whether a dozen
at town halls, the same deal
when you're when it's just the
2 of you at you know at a desk
or.
In you know it
chairs with proper distancing
and I you know did this Donald
Trump in last in July of 2020 I
ran outside yeah and a
100 degree heat. His idea not
you know for
an hour. There's no getting
away, I mean we don't have
subpoena powers, we can't have
this warning light and the it
and the police for a saying of
the Billy club, but it's as
close as you get to. It is
he's there at or
anybody and you can ask
questions and if you don't like
the answer you can follow up
and follow up again and you
know listen to what they're
saying and then decide when
you're going to move on and
you're much more in control
in terms of they can't get away
until you finish town answering
the question in the end
obviously if they're not going
to answer your question.
Nothing you can do about it.
But it it it creates a
different dynamic in which
the the principal the
interview way. How has to
confront your
Neither answered or make it
pretty obvious is going to
refuse to answer your question
and I remember we talked about
this on this show right after
you had that interview with
with Trump. A full hour you
have the whole show with Donald
Trump and to his credit.
He gave you a full hour, he
knows.
Your reputation as a tough
interviewer and he said I'll
give him an hour.
And you guys going at it, I
mean it was it was you know
chippy at times but it happened
and I asked you.
Are you in contact with the
Biden campaign he said we're
trying we love to do it.
I think he ought to do it of
course that never happened.
He's now president. They're not
giving sit-downs to almost
anyone ever. Can you
just keep you know knocking on
the door every weekend asking
and you know is there any way
that you and and other
colleagues from other networks
might start to put some
pressure if it's not you just
someone to to have him face
that sort of sustained
questioning on a regular basis
which he really
hasn't had his press know he
has and I it does a reason you
know there's a reason for
everything in politics and the
reason is obviously this is a
White House
that wants to protect this
president and doesn't have full
confidence in his ability to
handle those kinds of intense
situations where somebody is
going Preston. I you know, I'm
a realist enough to know that
he is not Don I don't
think he's done a single Sunday
show since he's become
president. I know he's done
some interviews with George
Stephanopoulos. But I think
they were for. Good
Morning America and then they
would only Afghanistan
interview where he
said a bunch of things that
turned out not right away and
that was not on it was not on
his Sunday show right so I'm
realistic enough to figure yank
on FOX News Sunday, you know
incidentally when we talked
after the I opted the Trump
interview in July of 2020.
I would head was in contact
with the Biden campaign and
they promised may that he will
do an interview with you.
This summer he will now.
Yeah and then and then they get
did they ever follow up on why.
They just said
you know we're in the campaign
and sorry,
yeah, yeah, and you know think
things have changed N
frankly with FOX you can always
say well you know we don't feel
we're getting a fair shake from
your network and but but they
had promised it and then they
backed down on it
and so I do I ask every wait
for it now I don't I mean
obviously we've made it clear
it's a standing invitation.
But my feeling is if he's not
doing. Sunday interviews with
meet the Press source or face
the nation or this week or CNN.
I'm not getting that interview
I'll give you an example Janet
Yellen the Treasury secretary
has done interviews with all of
the Sunday shows and in fact
has done too with
and there's talk with their was
struck on it she's going to do
it or not that you might do
another Sunday show this week
and we said well, you know
there you're on the second
round with all of our
competitors about giving us a
first round. Cricket's no
answers so you know it
is what it is you do you do
what you can and I will say for
all of my complaining.
And whining is never attractive
that that's why what has been
pretty good about giving us
gas. I mean we have Fauci last
week we got Lansky this week
we've had a number of Cabinet
secretaries of that the
secretary of state the national
security adviser DHS a few
weeks ago, so so I can